And I'll give this is Dr. Conner's and this section, we're going to talk about replacement
hormones, natural hormones support, what is usually out there.
So understand when somebody initially goes in with low thyroid symptoms and if they get
a doctor that won't test at least TSH and let's say TSH was elevated many times just based
upon the TSH number being elevated, they're prescribed thyroid medication.
Well, of course, we've already discussed how inappropriate that approach is, but here's
some brand names of different thyroid hormones, I'm not a prescribing medical doctor so I'm
not going to go into these things, but there are some things you want to learn about them.
Many of them are T4, remember T4 has to convert to T3 and there's a certain enzyme that causes
that conversion and that enzyme is mainly in the liver and in the gut, well, if I have
liver and got issues that conversion is not going to take place, maybe by one of my thyroid
issues is what's called under conversion.
So taking synthetic T4, it's not going to necessarily help all that much, so that could
be an issue.
You'll notice that some of these are synthetic and some of these are bioidentical.
So a lot of people might be like, I want to take a bioidentical, that's more natural, but
you might not react as well to a bioidentical.
So you'll see the difference in these are, they're synthetic, some are bioidentical, some
are T4 holy, some are T3 holy and some are a combination of T3 and T4.
So it's going to take some trial and error to see what works best for you as far as decreasing
your symptoms.
By this point in listening to this video, you know that drugs taking medications or even
a natural approach to supplements that we'll talk about in a few minutes of this presentation
is not even close to being the only thing to dealing with autoimmune disease and dealing
with Hashimoto.
So you understand that.
So the clinical picture again, if you go to a typical medical doctor, it's going to be
here's my symptoms, the TSH is above range, they're going to give you a medication and we're
going to recheck this in a year and by now, you know, this is foolishness.
Here's some problems that go along with a just standard medical approach.
Problem number one, many patients don't have obvious symptoms so you don't even know that
you have elevated TPO and thyroid gland antibodies.
You might be an autoimmune silent state.
Problem number two, your thyroid stimulating hormone can fluctuate greatly.
Remember I said, it can change throughout the day.
It is constantly bouncing up and down.
It is bouncing up and down completely based upon need.
So if I have a normal amount at eight o'clock in the morning, my TSH is going to be within
the normal limits.
If my thyroid gland and my thyroid hormone dips down because I used more thyroid hormone
because I just went for a jog, my TSH is going to be naturally increased in order to stimulate
more T3 and T4 production and if I did my blood test right at that point, it could be totally
skewed.
So that's why we don't just do TSH, right?
Problem number three, thyroid antibodies are routinely not tested.
So if you want to get a full thyroid test, you got to follow our recommendations about what
to do.
And then problem number four, the most commonly prescribed product, Synthroid, the level
thyroid, Thyroxid may not be the best therapy.
Problem number five is there's no concern for T4 to T3 conversion.
So if you use Synthroid, that's T4, and if you have conversion problems like I just spoke
about, you're going to have problems, continued.
Problem number seven, the thyroid gland destruction can be continuing to occur even though you might
have symptom relief if you started off with symptoms.
Then of course, you're just ignoring the whole autoimmune response that we've been talking
about through this entire course while we're not going to do that, right?
So we know that Hashimoto is not a thyroid-only problem, it affects our brain, it affects our
gut, it affects our bones, it affects our muscles, our whole body metabolism, our vascular system,
including possible heart issues and brain issues in our immune response in general.
And it certainly doesn't mean that it's my only autoimmune disease that I have going
on.
So back to the drugs that are being used, the other thing that you have to look at when
you start taking medication to balance out your symptoms and to replace what is missing
in your body, that you have to remember that everything works on a negative feedback loop.
So it's going to take some time to get that balanced when you're using these.
Of course, you're not only using these, you're doing everything that we talked about in this
course, but still, you need to replace your thyroid.
We can't end up having damage to the rest of our body because we just are so dogmatically
positioned against taking medication.
But remember, so once you figure out what's going to be best for me, whether it's a combination
of T3 and T4, whether it's bio-identical, whether it's the synthetic version, regardless
when you figure it out, don't forget some other issues that could go along with it.
So if you're like, I did well with synthetic for a couple of years and I just, I'm not doing
well at all.
I switched to arbor and I did well with that for a period of time.
And now I'm not doing very well with at all with that.
Remember, there's some other possible things.
These medications have exhibits.
There's common recipients in medication.
Excipients are feelers that they put in the medication, not because they're needed ugly
people making these medications, well, that might be true, but they're using them for specific
purposes.
Even supplements, some supplements have exhibits.
That's why most are private label supplements.
Most of them, not all of them, aren't excipient-free.
So common-excipiented supplements would be magnesium, steroid, and it's an anti-cakey
agent.
They will put sucrose, they will put talc, they'll put BHA as a preservative in a medication.
So those might be your triggers.
So it actually might be the excipient that is triggering your thyroid issue.
So actually, you're taking synthetic, it did well for a while.
You might start to develop antibodies and reactions to an excipient in the drug.
I know people that did really well with synthetic, and did do well with Levox level thyroxid.
Why is that?
It's the exact same drug.
It's because it was from two different drug companies, and there was excipients in one.
So the person was reacting to the excipient.
Don't forget that piece.
Also when you're trying to balance out this hormone and balance it out, you're levels.
Like how many micrograms should I be taking today?
Be very weary of clinical findings, your symptoms of hyperreactivity.
You do not want to stay.
There's times when you're trying to figure out your dosage, you're going to have a hyperactive
thyroid dose, because you're getting too much T3, and you can end up with palpitations
and feel like you got the eBGB's and it's crawling inside of you.
Okay, well you're trying to figure out the dosage, but if you're like that every single day
after you take your thyroid, you're taking too high of a dosage.
So you have to talk to your doctor about that, and that is not going to always show up on
a blood test.
You have to go by signs and symptoms with that.
That's why people, even when they're using a natural approach like taking, you know, our
clear thyroid product that's excipient-free and is just a desiccated thyroid, that they
can overtake a dose, and they're like, well, how many, how many should I be taking?
Well, it's like you're going to have to judge that for yourself based upon your signs
and symptoms.
Because if you're starting to get those palpitations and inner trembling, then you have to back
down on your dosage tomorrow and, you know, look at other things that could be triggering
that response.
So that's not so simple.
You've got to look at all the triggers in your life.
Make sure that you don't stay in a hyperactive response.
If you're taking a prescription medication, talk to the prescribed doctor about that, and you
reduce your dose, because that could be very dangerous.
Talk to about that before you're in a grave, your response, it could be very dangerous.
It could be lead to strokes.
The other thing we can't forget is other things that you're taking, other medications.
So if you're taking a glucocorticoid medication for, let's say, your injured shoulder, that
inhibits TSA release.
So that's going to inhibit your natural release of T3 and T4.
If you're taking a dopamine product, or you're taking a triotide, or you're taking, look
at the list of these, pause this presentation right now, and look at the list, some of these
are common.
I've underlined the ferrous sulfate.
Ferrous sulfate is a type of iron that is typically prescribed, or it's in poor iron supplements.
That can inhibit T4 absorption.
So look at this, pause this, maybe screenshot it, and save it, because there's drugs that
interfere with thyroid function.
So looking at your medical history about reactions to thyroid supplements, some things to consider.
Hey, I feel better, off my thyroid hormones, oh my gosh, where I just can't seem to tolerate
thyroid hormones at all.
It could be a sensitivity to the fillers, like we talked about.
It could be an autoimmune reaction to thyroid hormones.
You got to look at that too, or maybe I have this unable to tolerate bio-identical hormones.
You know, I can take synthetic, why can't I take bio-identicals, that's more natural.
Well, maybe you can't take T3 stimulation.
So that could be an issue.
Maybe I have an autoimmune reaction to thyroid hormones again.
So maybe I felt better with bio-identicals than I did with synthetics.
Is that a good thing?
Well, that could point to that I actually have my main problem with my thyroid as an underconversion
remember that conversion from T4 to T3, because bio-identicals are going to have T3 in them.
So what I didn't do as well with the box of thyroid or syntheroid, well, because that's
a T4.
So I have a really T4 to T3 under conversion.
So maybe I have really no change in my symptoms with any type of horrible replacement, it doesn't
change it.
Oh, you have to look at other underlining autoimmune disease.
Do I maybe have a malabsorption, or maybe I don't even absorb it this very well.
Yeah, I may have other dysfunctions.
Maybe I have neuroinflammation, other interferences with other medications.
That's why you got to look at this as a giant web, it's a bigger thing than just supplementing
with a drug or even a supplement than having this go away.
So there's big things to look at with this if you can't seem to get things calm down.
If my T3 replacement induces hyperactivity or, you know, some other crazy symptom, you
got to look at other things that are triggering my Hashimoto response.
Maybe I have dysautonomia or some other brain inflammation that's causing issues with my body's
response to thyroid medication.
So these are the questions you've got to ask yourself as you're going through this and
trying to figure out your balance.
You need to talk to your prescribing doctor about these.
What's better?
Just T4 replacement or T4, T3 combination or just T3 is sedentic better than bioidentical.
I don't think so.
It's whatever is going to work for you.
Are there mechanisms that impact thyroid absorption?
Yeah.
It's working on healing my gut and I work, this is what kind of, well, this is some of
the issues that can change my dosage.
If I had to have a high dosage in the beginning and now I've seen to getting some of these hyperreactions
like a gravestite reaction, like a hyper T3 reaction, maybe it's because I'm doing other things
to heal my gut now.
So I'm actually absorbing more of this.
So I can go down in dosage.
This is why you can't just get your TSH checked once a year or even once every three months and
it's just not enough.
You have to guide your dosage based upon signs and symptoms that you need to find a prescribing
doctor if you're using medication that will work with you on this.
Are there other immune reactions that are taking place?
To the fillers, reactions to just an immune response, it might die at that's causing issues
with the drug itself.
Do I have immune reactions to the thyroid hormones itself?
Trying to figure out this correct dosage is not easy, but you have to be patient with
yourself and work through it.
You need to reevaluate through blood work and you need to reevaluate through signs and
symptoms that have a doctor that will work through these.
There are natural possibilities, but certainly you have to talk to your prescribing doctor about
changing your prescription.
I recommend when you're going to go with a natural possibility that you go with something
without excipients, and that's the our brand, our clear thyroid support has no excipients,
and it doesn't have, you absolutely, if you watch the other videos, you can't be taking
anything with iodine.
This is just completely solely desiccated thyroid in our clear thyroid support.
That's all it is.
If you have been on thyroid medication for greater than a year or more, there's no way you're
going to be able to replace it with just a desiccated thyroid.
There's maybe, but probably not.
Because your thyroid works on a negative feedback loop, you've had enough shutdown of your
thyroid production that you're going to have to be on medication.
If you're newly diagnosed and you're trying to stay off medication, then get on a product
that doesn't have excipients in it, that has the fewest excipients, that doesn't have a
lot of other things in it.
You can be specific with the supplement, it gets your dosage.
Thyroxyl is good because it doesn't have iodine.
It has salinity, but some other things which are supposed to be more of a complete product,
but that is hard to find that specific dosage for the thyroid when you're doing that.
I think getting on just a more pure product of thyroid glandular is your best bet, but
that's just my opinion.
Try to unwind these webs is difficult, and it gets weary sometimes, but you're doing
good.
You watch a lot of videos so far, so hats off to you.
You deserve a cookie gluten free, obviously, but keep up the good work, know that you're
fighting the good fight, and you're not just doing this for yourself.
You're learning all this stuff to help other people.
Share this information with other people.
Get other people to our courses.
You're just helping be the best person you can be.
Know that I'm praying for you, and we're continuing to work through all of this.
Bye-bye.